Il a été conçu comme une prière en mouvement
pour la pluie, la fertilité
et une prospérité destinée à une société agricole.
Les danseurs, hommes et femmes,
étaient offerts aux temples
où ils agissaient comme intermédiaires entre le ciel et la terre.
Leurs corps dansants transportaient les prières des gens aux dieux
et la volonté des déités était offerte à travers eux
aux gens et à la terre.
Il y a beaucoup de courbes dans la danse khmère.
Nos dos sont arqués,
nos genoux sont pliés,
nos orteils sont recroquevillés,
nos coudes sont en hyperflexion
et nos doigts sont recourbés à l'envers.
Toutes ces courbes créent une impression de sinuosité.
C'est important car avant l'introduction des religions principales,
les Khmers et des gens dans le monde entier pratiquaient l'animisme.
Les serpents étaient très importants dans ce système de croyance
parce que leur mouvement fluide et curvilinéaire
imitait le débit de l'eau.
Pour invoquer le serpent dans votre corps dansant,
il fallait donc conjurer l'image des rivières quadrillant la Terre :
inspirer le débit des eaux porteuses de vie.
Comme vous pouvez le voir,
la danse classique khmère est une transformation de la nature,
du monde physique autour de nous et de notre propre univers intérieur.
Nous utilisons quatre principaux gestes de la main.
Peut-on les faire ensemble ?
Oui ? D'accord.
Ceci est un arbre.
Cet arbre va grandir
puis des feuilles vont pousser.
Après les feuilles,
il aura des fleurs
et après les fleurs,
il aura des fruits.
Le fruit tombera
et un nouvel arbre grandira.
Et ces quatre gestes
forment le cycle de la vie.
Ces quatre gestes sont ensuite utilisés
afin de créer un langage entier avec lequel les danseurs s'expriment.
Par exemple,
je peux dire :
« Je. »
En danse, cela serait...
Ou je peux dire...
« Hé toi, viens ici, viens ici. »
En danse...
« Viens ici »,
ou « Va, va ».
(Rires)
« Va. »
Et tout depuis
l'amour
à la tristesse
à —
(Tape des pieds)
la colère
peut être aussi exprimé à travers la danse.
Il y a une certaine magie
dans la façon de filtrer, de transformer et d'associer les choses
afin de créer des possibilités artistiques illimitées.
Le mot khmer pour art,
silapak,
à sa racine, veut en fait dire « magie ».
L'artiste —
le silapakar,
ou le silapakarani,
n'est rien de moins qu'un magicien.
Je suis très fier de dire
que j'appartiens à une longue lignée de magiciens,
depuis mon professeur, Sophiline Cheam Shapiro,
à ses professeurs, des célébrités du palais royal,
aux anciens danseurs d'Angkor
et aux premiers villageois
grâce auxquels la forme artistique a vu le jour.
Ceci dit,
notre patrimoine bien-aimé a déjà été presque complètement détruit.
Si vous portez des lunettes,
levez-vous s'il vous plaît.
Si vous parlez plus d'une langue,
Si vous avez la peau claire,
levez-vous s'il vous plaît.
Vos lunettes disaient que vous aviez accès aux soins de santé.
Cette deuxième ou troisième langue révélait une scolarité de haut niveau.
Votre peau claire disait que vous n'aviez pas à travailler sous le soleil.
Sous les Khmers rouges,
qui ont dirigé le Cambodge de 1975 à 1979,
nous aurions tous été morts,
pris pour cible à cause de notre supposé privilège.
Vous voyez,
les Khmers rouges ont observé le Cambodge
et ils ont vu des siècles de strictes inégalités.
Le roi et les quelques élites qui l'entouraient
avaient tous les plaisirs et le confort du monde
tandis que la grande majorité souffrait d'un travail harassant
et d'une grande pauvreté.
Un livre d'histoire n'est pas nécessaire pour voir que c'est la vérité.
Le mot khmer pour « je »,
pour « moi »
est khnhom.
Ce même mot peut aussi dire « esclave »
et les danseurs étaient appelés knhnom preah robam
ou les « esclaves de la danse sacrée ».
Les Khmers rouges cherchaient à abolir l'esclavage au Cambodge
mais pour ce faire, ils ont réduit tout le monde à l'esclavage.
Ils sont devenus l'oppression qu'ils voulaient éliminer.
Ils ont évacué la capitale
et ont envoyé les gens dans des camps de travail.
Ils ont brisé des familles
et ont endoctriné les enfants contre leurs propres parents.
Partout, des gens mouraient et étaient exécutés,
leurs vies abrégées par la maladie,
un travail excessif,
des exécutions et la famine.
Un tiers entier de la population du Cambodge a ainsi disparu
en moins de quatre ans
et parmi eux se trouvaient 90% des danseurs khmers.
En d'autres mots,
9 visions sur 10 d'une tradition et d'un futur ont été perdues.
Mais heureusement,
les professeurs de mon professeur,
Chea Samy, Soth Sam On et Chheng Phon,
ont renouvelé la forme artistique
à partir des cendres de la guerre et du génocide :
un étudiant,
un geste,
une danse à la fois.
Ils ont écrit l'amour,
la magie,
la beauté,
l'histoire et la philosophie de notre ascendance
dans les corps de la génération suivante.
Près de 40 ans plus tard,
la danse classique khmère a atteint de nouveaux sommets.
Elle existe pourtant toujours dans un environnement vulnérable.
Les effets désastreux de la guerre hantent toujours le peuple khmer.
La guerre est écrite dans nos corps,
elle se manifeste dans une transmission génétique de SSPT,
dans les familles aux prises avec une pauvreté cyclique
et dans les immenses fossés culturels et les barrières de la langue.
Et pourtant, la beauté est des plus résistantes.
La beauté a cette capacité de grandir n'importe où et partout,
n'importe quand.
C'est la beauté qui lie les gens à travers le temps et l'espace.
La beauté est une libération de la souffrance.
Comme les artistes khmers s'efforcent
de ressusciter notre culture et notre pays,
nous découvrons beaucoup de chemins à suivre pour avancer.
Dans une tradition où l'on connaissait rarement le nom des danseurs,
leurs origines,
leurs vies,
ou leurs sensations,
je vous propose d'avancer honnêtement et ouvertement à partir du « khnhom ».
Khnhom pas en tant qu'esclave,
mais en tant que service conscient.
Khnhom :
« Je »,
« moi »,
« florissant ».
Je m'appelle Prumsodun Ok.
Je suis khmer
et je suis américain.
Je suis l'enfant de réfugiés,
un créateur, un guérisseur
et un créateur de liens.
Je suis le premier étudiant masculin de mon professeur
dans une tradition comprise par beaucoup comme féminine
et j'ai créé la première compagnie de danse gay du Cambodge.
Je suis l'incarnation de la beauté, des rêves et du pouvoir
de ceux qui sont venus avant moi.
La convergence du passé, du présent et du futur
et de l'individuel et du collectif.
Laissez-moi endosser le rôle ancien et intemporel
de l'artiste en tant que messager
en partageant les mots de Chheng Phon :
« Un jardin avec une seule espèce de fleur
ou des fleurs d'une seule couleur
n'est pas un bon jardin. »
Ceci nous rappelle que notre force,
notre croissance,
notre survie
et notre existence même
résident dans la diversité.
C'est cependant aussi
un message de courage.
Car une fleur ne demande à personne la permission de fleurir.
Elle est née pour s'offrir au monde.
L'amour sans peur est sa nature.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)